guys everybody starts somewhere most
eSports players even the great ones had
early years filled with struggle
mediocrity and eventual improvement but
there are those for which greatness has
been ingrained since day one these are
the eSports players who didn't so much
ascend to godhood as were born deities
these are the top ten prodigies in all
of eSports starting our list off is a
true prodigy cut down in his prime in
2014 Brax or swag or whatever you want
to call him was one of the hottest
up-and-coming csgo talents in the world
it seems on paper riskier I think that
it's one of those more unexpected plays
though if and he was quick as well
jumping from windows straight on to that
that's so hard
visible under Kent started his CS
journey with 1.6 well he was just 15
years old and by the time he was 18 he
was known for lightning fast reactions
and pinpoint accuracy
people saw Bragg says potentially a
player who could lead to a new era of CS
glory it's nitro on the losing end of it
it's swag but that all came to an end
after the iBUYPOWER match-fixing scandal
stopped his career before it could even
begin that scandal and the resulting
bands set the region back years and it
left Brax his potential unfulfilled
taking our number nine spot is one of
the flashes players in Rainbow six siege
bolo
oh my god oh my god bola
what nothing fun bolo burst onto the
scene in 2016 at just 15 years old but
he was already hitting some of the
nuttiest shots anyone had ever seen they
know that these guys are gonna be
extended into kitchen
I think TSM might overextend your office
and I'll ignore bones just in the site
execute people take down to there but I
trade out from bolo now we stand a
little 3v3 in the post plant scenario
another one rotating down but Polly
would get one bola with three on the
round now looking for more eyes but now
in the hallway that's four for polo will
he get the age turning the corner beau
was so good that at first some people
even thought he was cheating
oh my god the moment bolo turned 18 he
signed with TSM that went on to win
Dreamhack Montreal and placed third at
the 2026 Invitational all in his first
year of competing this prodigy is well
on his way to becoming sieges next true
superstar at number eight we have rocket
league's greatest and perhaps most cocky
prodigy
you're not gonna score because you're
bad by 2018 skrub was finally old enough
to play and right off the bat he made a
statement he won the our LCS World
Championship in only his second season
competing and made it to the grand
finals of the next one
[Applause]
at just 16 years old who knows where his
career could go from here it's smash
ultimate there is no name more
synonymous with dominance than MK leo
which is why he takes the number 7 spot
on our list
[Applause]
MK lay was a player who seemingly came
out of nowhere to dominate smash 4
during its final few years and by the
time smash ultimate came out it was
clear that Leo would be a force in that
game as well but it probably caught most
people off-guard just how good MK Leo
was with dozens of titles under his belt
including Genesis and evil wins the
skill gap between him and his peers
couldn't be much wider waiting for the
3rd so smart he's gonna try to go low
Kenny spiked it he missed bribes and he
grabbed a Leo defeat fleet to be your
2019 Evo champion you can't win it you
can't run from it but in the end empty
leo will arise in grand final
our number six entry goes to the only
player to have a 100% TI win rate tops
at the beginning of tih Finnish player
Thompson was a completely unknown factor
he was great in pugs sure but he barely
had any tournament experience but when
Thompson got the call from og to join
them for Ti he came out swinging in his
debut Thompson
$3,000 in your pocket you come to tea ah
you got an email from no tell you're a
TI champion what at 20 years old tops
ins able to win di on his first try and
then he did it again
[Music]
look at this good diving in
kuroky in the facebook they're gonna get
into chasing Bears nose buddy
oh my god I can't believe this I got me
over singing this game for Yugi
[Applause]
even if he never wins another tournament
ever again
he's back-to-back wins at tea I proved
he wasn't just a prodigy but an all-time
great at the number five spot we have
one of the greatest players to ever
touch CS simple smoke could be really
rough for several times to get through
this he's from the moment simple started
playing counter-strike it was clear that
he had a talent unlike anyone had ever
seen there was just nothing he wasn't
good at if there was a drawback during
those days it was that he had a tendency
to be a little toxic he can be a
difficult person to play with like all
perfectionists but that's what he is he
had to take some time to grow up and
mature before competing at the top level
but when he did simple was unstoppable
in the open nearly gets caught toward
the sandwiches
[Music]
since then the Ukrainian prodigy has
amassed plenty of titles and given
counter-strike some of its most iconic
moments simple has evolved from a
hopeful prodigy with a few rough edges
to the very best in the game right
before our eyes out of all my teammates
you know ever in my entire career I
think simple was like one of the
youngest but also for being the youngest
he's one of the best players I've ever
been a team with it's kind of a
give-and-take you know you you have to
deal with his personality but if you can
actually manage it he's by far like one
of the best players in the world there
is no single player in CS that made a
bigger impression in his first year than
zai whoo and that's why he takes the
number four spot on our list in 2018 as
I will explode it onto the scene
seemingly out of nowhere completely
destroying pros and F BL all while he
was just 18 years old
a year later zai whoo was ranked the
best player in the world
this French prodigy has it all
incredible game sense lightning fast
reactions you name it and despite at
times being the hard carry on his team
he has managed to claw his way to a few
significant tournament victories in his
short time playing pro walk sake now
he's the only man standing vitality
opponent they've broken the streak and
they've taken Moscow at the epicenter
championship 2019 you got to say so I we
really deserves this one we could only
wonder what the rest of his career holds
but one thing is for sure this kid has
made a first impression we won't ever
forget at the number three spot is the
greatest Starcraft player ever flash
[Music]
flash began his career at the age of
fourteen and right off the bat everyone
recognized there was something different
about this kid the community dubbed him
little monster and as he grew up he
became one of the most dominant players
in Starcraft's history assuring in a new
era for the game paneling for the 10th
anniversary is the first time in world
cyber games flash taking it home he may
have started off as the little monster
but these days people just call him god
Flash for zero the greatest gamer of all
time reminds the world who's on top
flash has beaten everybody there is no
one like him and I don't know if there
ever will be again
sumail Tanana bookie year in 2015 he had
one of the most successful years in
eSports history and that's why he's
taking the runner-up spot on our list
in 2015 evil geniuses were left with a
huge hole to fill
after rtz and Zion left the team in came
sumail a 15 year old kid who could
seemingly do it all and outplay people
twice his age when I first met sumail I
knew this kid was gonna be big his
desire to compete at the highest level
his will to be a professional that was
the most prominent thing that I got from
him so when a spot opened up on Abel
Genesis semental was the first person
that we thought of as it turns out this
young prodigy was the key to eg success
in just a matter of months
sumail won DAC and the international
this level of success in a rookie year
was unheard of but some Mayo pulled it
off
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
in just one year sumail proved why he
deserves to be called the best and is by
far the greatest prodigy dota 2 has ever
seen taking the top spot on our list is
the unkillable demon king himself
faker these days you might think a faker
as the one constant force in League of
Legends but it wasn't always the case
there was once a time when a young 16
year old faker was trying to make a name
for himself in OGN but from day one he
proved he could bring down the best
players in the world just execute
ambition in that mid lane I know there
could be situations sometimes do you get
an ecology just something it's actually
get this a big tower dive they're gonna
come down this bottom Lane Captain Jack
the first target had lost boys not going
to escape either I don't think he's
gonna flash a double kill for faker
fakers rise was seen as a new era in
league of legends one that was all about
his otherworldly mechanics and after
taking worlds in his first year of
playing competitively faker eventually
won three World Championships to MSI
titles and eight to vesting ones he's
more than just a prodigy at this point
he is the goat well guys that is it for
the top 10 prodigies in all of eSports
now if you haven't done this already
subscribe to the score eSports YouTube
channel and head over to twitch.tv slash
the score eSports and give us a follow
and turn on notifications because we are
going live pretty regularly these days
and I'll see you next time
today let's take a look oh god at a few
examples of Shogun assassin now what is
this this is a film a series of films
American films that were made from a
series of Japanese films called lone
wolf and cub and through the different
sound track through the dubbing through
the repurposing of scene
I feel like it really changes the art
form you end up with a new movie it's
like someone took the Mona Lisa and
remixed it not that lone wolf and Cubs
the Mona Lisa but it's pretty damn good